um von der schottischen Stadt Edinburgh
nach London zu gelangen kann man
wirklich optimal Zug fahren zumindest
stand es im Internet auf der East Coast
mainline entlang der Nordseeküste
betreibt der Anbieter LNA ausgeschrieben
London north eastern railway über 70
Züge ich habe natürlich die erste Klasse
gebucht und wünsche euch viel Spaß mit
einem neuen zugtest
und damit einen wunderschönen guten
Morgen aus der schottischen Stadt
Edinburgh so spricht man das richtig aus
ich gehe hier gerade mal wieder den
nächsten Hügel hoch denn wir befinden
uns auf dem Weg zum Edinburgh
Hauptbahnhof bin aktuell nämlich
unterwegs für meine
reisemonopoly Folge Nummer 6 Nummer 5
ist jetzt schon abgeschlossen aber dafür
muss ich nach London das hat folgenden
Grund London hatten viel größeren
Flughafen von dort aus kann ich besser
fliegen und die Flüge sind halt
günstiger und ich dachte mir auch ich
muss ja nicht extra wieder von Edinburg
nach London fliegen man kann ja auch mit
dem Zug fahren und das geht sogar echt
schnell ich glaube es sind über 600 km
und der Zug schafft das in vier Stunden
[Musik]
ja ich bin hier natürlich ein bisschen
länger gewesen das könnt ihr alles in
der letzten Reise Monopoly folgend
nehmen und so sieht der Weg aus zurück
zum Hauptbahnhof
also wir sind hier in der Old Town aber
den Hauptbahnhof kann man sogar schon
sehen einfach genau hier durch gucken
und ich weiß ich habe schon oft genug
gesagt aber Edinburgh kann man auf jeden
Fall mal abchecken coole Stadt ist halt
ein bisschen anders hier als Großstadt
in Deutschland aber ganz nett wie ein
bisschen wie dreht so jetzt geht's
runter
und Leute ich werde natürlich nicht ich
wenn ich mir nicht wieder was überlegt
hätte wir fahren natürlich erste Klasse
und zwar die First Class im
LNA Zug von Schottland nach London und
das cool ist diese Züge sollen wohl echt
richtig cool und gut ausgestattet sein
mit einem guten Service dann zumindest
drin Internet und hier sind weiß auch
schon an der Straße fahren Bahnhof
Edinburg
ich muss zu Plattform direkt am Anfang
hier und das geil ist wir haben 28.12
der Zug ist aber schon da so sieht
übrigens mein Ticket aus und ich muss zu
kaufen
mit dem ich noch nie in meinem Leben
gefahren bin ich okay und hier sind wir
auch schon
ich bin zwar kein trainspott aber wir
gucken uns den Zug einmal schon von
vorne an wir sollten zu ne okay jetzt
aber schnell zum Platz
[Musik]
steht schon mein Ziel
ja
[Musik]
also der Sitz ist soweit in Ordnung ich
ist auch schon mal bequemer nur ich habe
halt keine Kopfstütze sondern eine
Armlehne jetzt das Ding ist irgendwie
kaputt das muss ja eigentlich ein Punkt
Abzug geben mir wurde dann auch direkt
die Menükarte gereicht denn Essen und
Trinken ist in der ersten Klasse
komplett inklusive so sieht die aus und
natürlich kommt erstmal drauf an wie
viel uhr Reis mit dem Zug es gibt
Frühstück als auch mittags und abends
Angebote natürlich sind die Gerichte
alle sehr schottisch bzw britisch
geprägt die meisten Reisenden bestellen
denke ich das voll leider Menü das
enthält dann Bacon diesen schwarzen
Pudding ist in Schottland so ein Ding
dazu dann Hash Browns Boden und Pilze
und natürlich auch verschiedene
Variationen ich habe mich allerdings an
morgen für was vegetarisches entschieden
es gibt nämlich auch hier sehr viele
vegane und vegetarische Alternativen
einfach weil ich da noch keinen Bock auf
so ein deftiges Frühstück hatte wir
haben den Bahnhof dann pünktlich
verlassen und haben uns auf den Weg nach
London gemacht und ich war echt gespannt
auf die Strecke
[Musik]
für mich dann erstmal mit einem
Orangensaft und dann kam auch schon
ziemlich schnell die Dame mit den heißen
Getränken
und jetzt genießen wir aber erstmal die
echt coolen Landschaften die ich mit dem
Zug passiert habe
vor allem der erste Teilabschnitt der
Strecke entlang der Nordseeküste ist
wirklich sehenswert und jetzt schauen
wir uns mal mein phänomenales Essen an
ich habe dann tatsächlich nur Sonntag
vegane Wurst im Brötchen bekommen mit
Ketchup mehr nicht klar ich habe es auch
bestellt aber ich dachte halt dass da
auch dann die Kartoffeln und so weiter
dabei sind dem war leider nicht so ich
habe dann gefragt ob ich die noch
bekommen kann und irgendwie kam da
nichts mehr und dann dachte ich mir
herkommen jetzt ist auch egal na ja kann
man nichts machen geschmeckt hat soweit
in Ordnung dazu gab es da noch einen
Kaffee und ich habe auch noch zwei
pepsis getrunken bisschen ungesund aber
kann man drüber wegsehen also Getränke
auch alkoholische kann man unlimitiert
bestellen nach gut vier Stunden hatte
ich die Strecke dann auch schon fast
hinter mir und wir sind im Außen Bezirk
von London angekommen sind dann noch am
Arsenal Stadion vorbei gefahren sehr
geil ich bin der größte Fußballfan und
ja zack dann war ich auch schon im Kings
Cross Bahnhof zentralen London sehr
entspannte Fahrt muss ich sagen
okay Leute angekommen in London
okay Leute hinter mir könnt ihr sehen
London Kings Cross ist glaube ich hier
der Hauptbahnhof oder sowas wieder
Hauptbahnhof ich muss sagen ich war
jetzt vier Stunden zwölf glaube ich
unterwegs war eine sehr sehr entspannte
Reise mit wenigen Highlights also die
Aussicht war ganz cool aber sonst ist
irgendwie nicht viel passiert was ich
euch hätte zeigen können ich habe
trotzdem versucht alles bestmöglich zu
verfilmen und ja ich denke am Ende ist
jetzt ein halbwegs gutes Video
entstanden wir machen jetzt natürlich
noch die gesamte Bewertung moinsen vom
ganzen Zug und dazu Switch mir aber in
meinem Büro schauen wir jetzt noch
London an und dann geht's aber auch
schon wieder zurück nach Deutschland
weil hier war ich auch letztens noch ich
glaube genau da ging mein Video vom
Eurostar los ne
okay mittlerweile wieder angekommen zu
Hause und wir kommen noch zu
abschließenden Bewertung des Zuges wie
immer bei meinem zugfest gibt es fünf
verschiedene Kategorien und insgesamt
können maximal 25 Sterne erreicht werden
starten mit der ersten und zwar Komfort
habe ich drei von fünf Sterne gegeben
das Nackenkissen oder diese nackenlehne
war halt nicht angebracht und ja sonst
war es so okay war jetzt nicht unbequem
aber ich habe auf jeden Fall schon
meinen ersten Klassen deutlich besser
gesessen deswegen iPhone 5 machen wir
weiter mit Essen hier gebe ich ebenfalls
drei von fünf Sterne diese vegane Wurst
mit dem Brötchen war ganz lecker lag
wahrscheinlich auch am Ketchup mehr habe
ich ja dann nicht mehr bekommen kann
auch nicht bewerten also okay iPhone 5
ich hätte ein bisschen mehr erwartet vor
allem auch für den Preis den ich euch ja
noch gar nicht genannt habe Service hier
habe ich vier von fünf Sterne gegeben
war ich so zufrieden ich wurde oft
bedient immer gefragt ob ich noch was
trinken will deswegen ist hier von fünf
vier denke ich ganz okay
naturerlebnisfaktor ebenfalls 4 von 5
der Anfang der Strecke hat mich echt
umgehauen also gerade diese Aussicht
schön an der Nordsee ich wusste gar
nicht dass sie Nord sieht so schön sein
kann aber gerade mit dem Klippen und
diesen schönen grünen Wiesen sah das
wirklich fantastisch aus und ich war ein
bisschen überrascht also falls ihr diese
Strecke mein Fahrrad achte drauf dass
ihr vor allem am Anfang nicht aufs Handy
guckt sondern nach draußen ist lohnt und
zu guter Letzt Preisleistung ich habe
bezahlt 137 Pfund sind umgerechnet 163
Euro gewesen was ich schon relativ teuer
findet zumindest für das was mir dann
geboten wurde klar ich habe erst einen
Tag vorgebucht dennoch ist das ein
stolzer Preis ich bin aber auch vorher
schon damit konfrontiert worden das
Schottland wirklich Arsch teuer ist auf
der anderen Seite habe ich natürlich
auch mit dem Zug in der ersten Klasse
über 600 km zurückgelegt deswegen gebe
ich hier drei von fünf Sterne kommen wir
auf einen gesamten Ergebnis von 17 von
25 Minuten stellen ist denke ich in
Ordnung war ganz cool Leute vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen Daumen nach oben und abonnieren
für weitere Tests und wir sehen uns haut
rein ciao